brit's attorney called it a major
victory the singer's estranged dad jamie
spears who's been conservative of her
estate for 13 years says he intends to
work with the court to prepare for his
replacement but there's a catch jamie
says he'll step down quote when the time
is right
legal expert rachel stockman says
there's no clear timeline he wants to
talk to all the parties and he wants to
get a plan in place to make sure it's
done in a what he calls respectable way
that's good for britney spears
jamie's filing obtained by et also
claims that quote if the public knew all
of the addiction and mental health
issues ms spears has struggled with they
would praise mr spears for the job he
has done
there's more jamie goes scorched earth
on his ex-wife lynn spears it's getting
pretty nasty
he claims britney pays for the mansion
in louisiana where lynn lives including
all of her utility bills and weekly maid
service he says it's all added up to a
total of two million dollars
jamie also claims lynn quote exploited
their daughter's pain and trauma by
publishing a book about brittany the
chapter that was
the hardest for me to read was
when brittany was hospitalized lynn sat
down exclusively with e.t for her memoir
through the storm in 2008 it was just
eight months after brittany's second
hospitalization i'm begging the
ambulance please let me ride please let
me go let me go with you i'm her mom
and they tell me
if you don't hush we're gonna restrain
you
lynn did not address her ex-husband's
claims but she did tell e.t in a
statement she's pleased he's agreed to
step down
[Music]